[Music]
hello i'm rachel andrew a technical
writer on the chrome team and i'm here
to talk to you about how we are trying
to make it easier to build for the web
when we talk to developers informally or
via surveys we hear the same thing over
and over again
making websites work well across
browsers is hard
knowing when it's safe to use new
features is hard
this slide shows the results of the 2021
state of css survey with browser
compatibility top of the list
interoperability meaning the support of
features across browsers was also cited
as the biggest barrier to adopting
technology in the mozilla dna report
and in research conducted by google
making a design or experience work the
same across browsers is consistently
listed as a top challenge for web
developers
here's an example
the gap property lets you make even gaps
between grid and flex items or columns
in a multi-core container
it first appeared in css grid layout
initially named grid gap with long hand
properties of grid row gap and grid
column gap
just after grid layout landed in
browsers the decision was made to rename
the property so it could be used more
generally in other layout methods
it became gap along with row gap and
column gap
this means we don't need to have
duplicate properties such as flex row
gap and instead can use one set of
properties for gaps between things in
layouts it was then specified to work
with flexbox
and in october 2018 firefox shipped the
gap property in flex layouts
in july 2020 chrome shipped it
in april 2021 safari shipped it
so we had a gap of two years and six
months before we had the gap property in
flexbox in all evergreen browsers
okay but we've got progressive
enhancement and feature queries we can
at least use margins for older browsers
and gap where it's supported right
sadly not in this case
because the gap property is supported in
grid
testing for at supports gaap returns
true
feature queries are pretty simple they
just check to see if the browser can
parse that property and value if it
means something to it
so there's no way to test for gap 1m
in flex layout
therefore this partial implementation
meant that developers had to wait for
over two years after it landed in
firefox
a gap of over two years to use a
straightforward feature that would have
cleaned up their code and made css more
intuitive
this is just one example of the problem
we see this fragmentation of support
again and again with different browsers
taking the lead in landing something and
then a gap of months to years before it
lands in the other browsers
to add to this problem as soon as gap
became available at all in flexbox folk
like me started making demos and talking
about this feature
and this is a bit confusing for people
who tried the demos and found it didn't
work in their browser
they could then go look check can i use
rmdm but it's all extra work and takes
time
it's frustrating to get excited about
something and then find that you can't
really use it
especially when this pattern keeps
repeating
so why does this happen
why do features seem to take so long to
become usable
most developers have been frustrated by
this situation at one time or another
it might not have been gap but unless
you've been very lucky there will be at
least one feature you've wanted to use
and then you discover didn't work or
work differently in one browser
new platform features come from a
variety of sources but often the initial
idea and prototyping is done by one
browser vendor
for example the initial grid layout spec
was created by microsoft and implemented
an initial form in internet explorer 10.
an engineer at mozilla did a lot of the
work to figure out how the subgrid
feature for grid layout should work
and so subgrid landed in firefox first
as they'd already done this work
the container queries feature is being
prototyped in chrome
different browsers take the lead on
different features and so the feature is
likely to show up there first
this prototyping work is done in
collaboration with people from other
browsers
for css that's through the css working
group
it's very important that a feature can
be implemented across all browsers and
isn't designed in such a way that it
would be impossible for another browser
to add the feature
that would lead to a permanent gap in
support which no one wants to happen
there's no benefit to any browser to
have a feature that isn't supported
across all browsers because web
developers won't fully adopt it
however when it comes to doing that
implementation work in the other
browsers a feature has to be prioritized
browsers are just like any other product
there are many features that could be
added and so the business has to figure
out which ones to do first
sometimes internal changes might need to
be made to make a feature possible
a good example of this is the rendering
ng work
this rewrite of the rendering
architecture fixed a huge number of bugs
but features like subgrid were held up
behind it waiting for grid to be
implemented in the new architecture
for most developers the time a new
feature is considered safe to use it's
once it's landed in the three major
browser engines
chrome firefox and safari
yet what we tend to see is a timeline
like this
we get a lot of noise about a thing at a
point where it isn't usable and
sometimes very little announcement when
it actually lands everywhere
by that point it's old news and the
developer influencers have moved on to
the next shiny thing
there were two issues here
firstly the interoperability problem the
fact that features take a long time to
be usable across browser
this might be because the feature hasn't
yet been implemented or has been
implemented in a buggy or inconsistent
way
the second issue is that of confusing
messaging
blog posts videos and tutorials all
appear at a point when the new thing is
actually unavailable to most developers
it can appear that a thing is ready to
use when it's not leading to wasted time
and effort
so what can we do to fix these issues
the first issue is one that browser
vendors are uniquely positioned to solve
if vendors place a priority on reducing
fragmentation
by reducing the time it takes for apis
and features to ship we can bring the
time down from the first to the last
browser to land a feature
by working together browsers can ensure
that bugs and features that prevent them
from being useful are solved quickly
and this collaboration is already
happening
the web platform test project is a
cross-browser test suite for the web
platform
tests are written in a way that ensures
they can run in all browsers
they let browser engineers know that
their implementations are compatible
with other implementations as they work
on a feature
they help to prevent regressions where a
previously working feature develops a
bug due to some change in the browser
however not all fragmentation is equal
some bugs are of a much higher priority
to developers and may even stop them
using a feature at all
so we've been working to prioritize
these fixes
the compact 2021 project focused on five
areas where differences between browsers
were causing problems to developers
flexbox
grid position sticky aspect ratio and
transforms
over the course of 2021 interoperability
bugs were fixed in all these areas by
all browsers
for example
flexspace's content which was
implemented in firefox is now also
implemented in chrome and webkit
firefox fixed a percentage height bug in
flexbox
the edge team at microsoft ledwork on
css grid through the grid ng project
which launched in chrome 93
this was part of the rendering ng work i
mentioned earlier
this increased the compact 2021 score
for grading chromium from 3 to 97
and as part of this work gap landed in
safari
making it available to us to use cross
browser
so this project helped to fix a bunch of
annoying issues in the platform and all
vendors were keen to do more
and so earlier this year interrupt 2022
was launched
this time the selection and
prioritization of features was made by
representatives of all browsers and
third parties who involved the platform
this robust prioritization effort
resulted in 15 areas the existing five
from compact 2021 plus 10 new ones
these new areas of focus are those which
are most troublesome for developers when
building for the web
cascade layers
css color spaces and functions
new viewport units
scrolling
subgrid the contain property the dialog
element form controls typography and
encodings web compact issues
this effort also includes three areas of
investigation
places that we know need improvement but
where the current state of
specifications or tests is not yet good
enough to be able to score progress
and these are editing pointer and mouse
events and viewport measurements
by working together we can hopefully
work out what should be done in these
areas and ensure they have good
specifications and tests and
improvements can be implemented
work is already happening in all of
these areas and you can follow along
using the interop 2022 dashboard
so what about the second issue
the fact it isn't always clear to
developers whether a feature is usable
yet when looking at developer news and
resources
there's always a temptation to talk
about the new exciting shiny thing and
there's a place for that many of you
like to know what's coming and also
enjoy getting involved by testing new
features and reporting bugs
however we feel it's important that you
know when looking at our resources what
the real status of a feature is
and we're working to make sure that the
resources you see from the chrome team
are clear in that regard
on web.dev we've launched a number of
fundamental courses with more to come
showing you how to use core web platform
technologies
we're identifying the places where we
can provide solid cross-browser
information to help you build great
websites and applications
be that in terms of performance
accessibility or beautiful and usable ux
we're also contributing to web
documentation through our support of the
open web docs project
this project is ensuring that we have
first-class documentation on mdn along
with up-to-date browser compatibility
data
we even use that data in our web.dev
articles showing the browser status of
features we write about
we're trying to be clearer when
something is experimental in chrome
currently only available in chrome and
when it's ready for you to use because
it's supported everywhere
so the good news is that when working to
make things better the flexbox gap
feature is now something that's safe for
you to use it's available in all
evergreen browsers
we hope that by the end of this year
you'll be seeing an improvement in all
of these areas we're focusing on along
with our colleagues at the other
browsers through the interrupt 2022
project and because there will always be
something of a gap even if it's a
smaller one we're working to ensure that
our messaging is clear when we talk
about features
we want you to enjoy building for the
web to have fewer frustrations
so our aim is to do our best to fix the
gaps and to be clear and honest with you
about the places where they still exist
we're starting with our own sites
publishing content on web.dev that is
browser agnostic
that you should feel confident is well
supported and current best practice to
help you build sites today
on chrome developers you'll find more of
our vision for the web
the things we're experimenting with in
origin and developer trials
and information about changes to chrome
that will help you plan
and do talk to us and let us know what
you think of the content we publish and
of efforts such as interrupt 2022 you
can keep up to date via our newsletter
and talk to us about the chrome
developers twitter account
thank you for watching and being part of
io i hope you're now excited to see how
much better we can make web development
by bridging the gap this year
[Music]
you